as don's week at the warehouse was
wrapping up
it was time to come clean with his
employees actually everybody
uh got an announcement to me don't
nobody want to hear your bull
newbie okay don't nobody want to hear it
i think you will care about this one so
uh
gather around i'm not actually a new
employee
you can say that again you a waste of
space as far as i'm concerned can't get
another done in time
like like a snail over here
i am actually
president of the company you're on
undercover boss
[Music]
tv show yeah what in this week
since i've been working here amongst you
i uh got to hear each and every one of
your stories
it's just about and uh you know you know
i was just playing right you know
i was just trying to lighten the mood in
the workplace and whatnot okay thank you
joseph
bill buddy
you're telling me that your car broke
down and it hasn't been working right
ever since well
i want to get you a new ford explorer
oh my god thank you so much mark that
means
so much to me my whole family died in
one day
thank you huge car crash huge man we
were having a family picnic
and then this truck just came on through
and just killed everybody it chopped
everyone's heads off eleanor
you were worried that you were not gonna
be able to afford college for your two
two boys and uh i'm starting a college
fund
for them both putting ten thousand
dollars in each one of them
this is amazing i'm so grateful
i i can't make no family anymore because
my dick got chopped up in the accident
and now i pee out the side sometimes i
wake up in the middle of night i just
i start to pee let's go right in my
mouth
sometimes poop come out the other side i
don't even know what dick is in
eight pieces okay you know he just give
me a raise i didn't answer for no kind
of scholarship
joseph i'm gonna get i'm gonna go and
get to you right now okay dude i
mentioned i was a prostitute since the
age of seventeen
fifteen ten chelsea seven children three
childhood prostitutes since i was three
i was in
i was a prostitute in a wound i do put
his pp in my my mama
and they got inside of me and then and
they gave me money joseph's please man
you have been rude to me
since the moment i came here come on man
i mean i was playing with you i knew you
was the boss the whole time man
look at this fake-ass mustang ow that's
my real mustache joseph it really hurt
you're fired get out of here i can't
understand what
get out of here i got a ra i got a rare
condition that make me unlikable don't
you don't joseph
pants lance you've been in the urinal
with me you've seen me in the urine
i'm sorry but do not engage my dick
don't say pieces joseph leave lancelot
it's true so then give me a little bit
of money no
it's not gonna happen can i have a
joseph he did
he did joseph leave norman out of this
who was norman
the foreman norman the foreman that's
his name
i know that i work intimately with him
no you don't you're fired
all right i'm going all right you're out
the door with you joseph i am sorry
about that
ah is he gone
okay uh betty
when you told me that your father passed
away
it hit me because my father passed away
but my dick got chopped up dope joseph
my dick got chopped that is so
disrespectful joseph what are you doing
i thought you left joseph
like gristle off of thanksgiving turkey
you're lying and i got a crystal dick
joseph that's wildly inappropriate
straight meat gristle
just hanging out here right here right
now you can't see does that
coming up you know you have so many
siblings and just to know
that we both share a familial bond and
that there's nothing that can take that
away
but my dick got chopped up joseph where
how did you
you